die ganze Social Media Welt kennt
bibisbeautypalace und das erst recht
seit der Trennung von Julian Claßen also
ihrem Ehemann vor einem Jahr und eben
seit dieser Trennung ist es auch extrem
still und bibisbeautypalace geworden sie
hat nichts mehr geteilt nichts mehr
gepostet und nichts mehr hochgeladen ist
aber ob wir sie noch am Leben denn diese
Bilder von dir wurden vor einigen Wochen
geliebt wo sie mit ihrem jetzigen Freund
einen Konzert besucht hat und jetzt hat
bibisbeautypalace endlich vor einigen
Tagen mal ein Lebenszeichen proaktiv von
sich selber in die Social Media Welt
hinausgeschrieben denn sie hat einen
Link einen ominösen YouTube-Link in ihre
instagram-bio gepostet der uns
allerdings wenn man darauf klickt nur zu
einem privaten Video führt und die
Gerüchteküche sprudelt seitdem dieser
Link in dieser bio ist den
Spekulationen rum wie sonstwas er
handelt es sich dabei um das Erklärvideo
das mittlerweile nach endlich mal einem
Jahr
Jahre lang ist die Trennung nämlich
mittlerweile fast schon genau her weil
online geht wird Baby dort endlich mal
sagen was Phase ist ist es ihr Statement
oder
löst sie vielleicht sogar den prank auf
denn einige gehen noch immer davon aus
dass sie gar nicht mit Julian
auseinander gegangen ist dass das ganze
nun soziales Experiment war weil Julian
nur plötzlich auch Stress hat mit Tanja
die haben sich gegenseitig aus dem BIOS
entfernt die haben die Bilder entfernt
es ist unfassbar es ist Kindergarten pur
so oder so hat sich jeder gedacht Mensch
dieser Videolink da in Bibis Bio der
führt zu einem privaten Video das heißt
das Video geht vielleicht heute abend
online oder in der Woche und zwei Wochen
jeder hat gewartet jeder auf Bibis
Account gegangen ist ihr neu gefolgt sie
hat unfassbar viele neue Follower
gemacht weil sie benachrichtigt werden
wollten wenn dieses Video online geht
ich habe outside the box gedacht und hat
mir gedacht Mensch
vielleicht gibt es das Video ja schon
vielleicht ist es nicht ein Video was
noch nicht veröffentlicht wurde sondern
ein Video was schon mal veröffentlicht
wurde und privat gestellt wurde
[Musik]
Kommissar Sherlock Laser von uns zu Luca
hat die Lösung gefunden
denn ich habe vor zwei Jahren auf Bibis
Ferienhaus in Spanien reagiert und ihr
kennt mich ich bin Ehrenmann wenn ich
auf was reagiere dann gebe ich auch
Credits ich verlinke das Video mit dem
Titel in der Beschreibung
und dreimal dürft ihr raten
wo dieser Link hier in Bibis Bio auch
drin vorkommt
wollte das Wissen in meiner
Videobeschreibung das Video was in Bibis
Bio verlinkt ist ist der exakt gleiche
Link wie der Link zur Ferienhaus
roomtour und siehe da die Ferienhaus
roomtour wenn man auf das Video drauf
klickt ist es exakt ebenfalls ein
privates Video warum hat Bibi ihr
Ferienhaus Video auf privat gestellt und
den Link in Ihre Instagram Video
gepostet fragt ihr euch jetzt
keine Sorge ich habe die Antwort
[Musik]
du kannst alle verarschen
wie groß ist bibisbeautypalace
Wikipedia 1,55 m
1,55
iss Internationale Raumstation ist Bibi
eine außerirdische ist sie ein Alien hat
sie etwas mit dem Weltall zu tun naja
wir wollen nicht so wildspekulieren was
man auf jeden Fall weiß ist dass die ISS
die Internationale Raumstation
regelmäßig die ganze Zeit um die Erde
rumfliegt sie sieht alle Länder von oben
unter anderem auch Spanien und was steht
in Spanien
Bibis Finca Villa
[Musik]
zehn Buchstaben
hat
Bibi Klassen wie viele verschiedene
Buchstaben gibt es im Wort Bibi
was ist Platz 2 der stärksten
staubsaugermarken der Welt
Mile wo hat Miele sein Hauptsitz in
Gütersloh wer kommt ebenfalls aus der
Nähe von Gütersloh Laser Luca Bielefeld
direkte Nachbarstadt von Gütersloh und
was ist Laser Luca
[Musik]
eine Maschine
Laser luca ist eine Maschine
was sind Maschinen Maschinen sind
Roboter Miele Miele macht Staubsauger
Staubsauger rund Staubsauger Roboter was
hat was hat Bibi mit einem
Staubsaugerroboter zu tun wurde sie
vielleicht von einem angefahren
dieses Bild ist letztens aufgetaucht
dabei sieht man einem blauen Fleck an
Bibis arm aber wie schafft der am Boden
fahrende Staubsauger Roboter von Miele
der influencerin bibisbeautypalace einen
blauen Fleck am Arm zuzufügen da kommt
doch gar nicht daran außer Boden
[Musik]
liegen wann liegen Leute am Boden man
gefallt ist
[Musik]
warum sollte man fallen wenn einem
vielleicht ein Bein gestellt wo das kann
nicht sein bibisbeautypalace wurde so
lange nicht gesehen
[Musik]
ihr Ferienhaus und Spanien es hat so
viele Treppen und Höhenunterschiede weil
es am Berg gebaut wurde ist
wahrscheinlich eine Treppe
runtergefallen und dieses Erlebnis also
tragisch dass sie dementsprechend die
roomtour auf privat gestellt hat
[Musik]
also bibi ist in Ihrem Ferienhaus die
Treppe runter gestürzt und wurde dann am
Boden liegend vom Staubsauger Roboter
angefahren der eher einen blauen Fleck
am Unterarm zugefügt hat
mit einer Verletzung am Arm kann sie
nicht den Aufnahmeknopf der Kamera
betätigen wodurch keine Videos kamen
so was heilt allerdings relativ schnell
also das kann nicht der Grund sein da
muss noch mehr vorgefallen sein
[Musik]
hin
hat drei Buchstaben wisst ihr was auch
drei Buchstaben hat Leo leo ist Bibis
Sohn und wie alt ist Leo 4 4 Jahre alt
wann hat er Geburtstag im Oktober und
der Oktober ist der einzige Monat im
Jahr der zwei OS beinhaltet OS an was
erinnert euch ein oh
[Musik]
an einen Mund ein Mund der gerade etwas
essen möchte leo hat Hunger können sich
vierjährige bereits alleine etwas zu
essen kochen oder bestellen nein sie
sind auf ihre Eltern angewiesen
Bibi lag allerdings am Boden und Kinder
nehmen generell alles in den Mund erst
recht wenn sie Hunger haben dann essen
die einfach alles was hat sich Leo wohl
gedacht als er dort Bibi auf dem Boden
liegend gesehen hat
Mittagessen leo hat Bibi gegessen und
was passiert wenn man zu viel gegessen
hat richtig man muss kacken können
vierjährige Jungs bereits alleine auf
die Toilette gehen und kacken nein dafür
gibt es Winde es
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
was finden wir auf Bibis Rasierschaum
bilou
ein Herz im Logo und wo finden wir exakt
das gleiche Herz beim Pampers Logo
jetzt ergibt alles Sinn
die Windel konnte
nach dem Schiss von leologischerweise
nicht gewechselt werden weil Bibi
gegessen wurde deshalb hat sich Leo so
fett in seine Windel geschissen dass
diese geplatzt ist und wo scheißt man in
der Regel vor einem Fenster weil man
dort lüften kann weil man einen schönen
Ausblick hat und wo steht das Ferienhaus
in Spanien an einem Berg an einem Berg
der Meilen weit runter geht zum Teil zum
Fuß folgt das Gewicht der Scheiße hat
das Haus zusammen einstürzen gemacht das
ist runtergefallen install die ganze
Scheiße bedeckte das ist unfassbar
das Video wurde privat gestellt weil das
Haus aufgrund der Scheiße kaputt
gegangen ist
[Musik]